let's pop the story real quick to get
some context here we have this from
timcast.com de blasio says people will
be forced to accept covet vaccines if
their quote paychecks depend on it wow
this dude was giving an interview and he
basically said
i will destroy your life to get you to
do what we want you to do
and i was just like if you want to live
in that city and you want to live under
his boot and lick it they like it feel
free to do it if you i'd leave if you
want to call anything white supremacy
that's it right there if you look at the
the vax mandates who it predominantly
affects the the the consequences of it
especially in new york city especially
with people of color holy freaking
wilhelm
right
one of my favorite images of this year
videos really is him alone in times
square dancing with his wife
when everyone was not allowed to be in
there everyone was told get away you're
not allowed to come to times square only
the special elites only the people who
give out the orders will be
celebrating and dancing in the middle of
it as the order followers will kick
everyone out it was disgusting look at
this and the new york times made that
one of the photos of the year that they
were celebrating and toting us something
great yeah they didn't show uh bill de
blasio dancing there by himself with his
wife with police officers protecting
them meanwhile the governor's a mass
murderer oh yeah they kicked out
everyone from times square and then they
had their private dance so you could
have a little prom night that's cute
it's cute right
i think i think i i like your point that
people with kids people with families
should leave there's really nothing that
they could do i will not fault anybody
for leaving if there's really nothing
else they can do but i did write a piece
for tim cass it was in august i think it
was called here's how new yorkers can
fight back against medical mandates
where i interviewed somebody from the
new york young republican club and they
talked about um
basically how they're like staging like
sit-ins and anti-mass protests and
rallies and i think non-compliance is
like a truly american virtue i mean it's
what basically birthed this country and
birthed this nation and i would be i
would hate to just have everyone retreat
when i think i think there is a silent
majority i think it's time for them to
speak up and i know everyone's so tired
of them of everyone's saying oh silent
majority sign majority but i think it's
a real thing and i think people are
scared and if you and if you you can
afford to not leave and if you can
afford to you know not comply i think
you should i totally agree were they in
the city yep yeah so like that's a
different like the city is a whole
different world from the rest of new
york yeah i said this last time like
this new york city is a little p at the
bottom of the state that kind of
dictates the policy for the rest of this
giant state
and they vote sometimes overwhelmingly
red while the city votes blue
i would i would hope for non-compliance
if you can that's the way to go
non-violent civil disobedience yes it's
as simple as people just being like no
just say no
and then we will not comply it's like a
perfect american phrase and it's just
like we forgot about it or we attribute
it to like white supremacists or
something yeah ben shapiro did not
forget daily wire guys did not forget
yeah that's like they're they're all
their you know logo icons avatars or
whatever do not comply we will not
comply it's crazy how but they also
retreated you know like they left a
state
that was pretty dystopian like new york
but it's good to say not not comply but
i also think sometimes
it's kind of a few and it sends a
message to the state i i think it's kind
of good in some sense because it does
send a message and i think that people
are going to look at that and be like
hey we need to make a change or you know
hey something's up some people argue
that you're voting with your feet right
by staying in new york city you're
paying their taxes you're part of their
workforce you're incentivizing people to
say i will control every aspect of your
life and you will obey and you will live
underneath my boot no i won't i'm gonna
go to florida i'm gonna go to new
hampshire i'm gonna go to west virginia
i'm gonna go to texas i'm gonna go where
my rights are respected where my money
actually goes towards the greater good
and doesn't go towards discriminating
against people doesn't go towards giving
people less opportunities because they
didn't do a procedure that the
government bureaucrat wanted them to do
and it's it's sickening what's happening
in new york city and there are some
people standing up there was recently a
large number of people arrested because
they went to restaurants and they said
hey um we're not going to comply with
the whims of government we're not going
to ask the government permission and get
their permission slip to eat here and
they were asked to leave they said no
and they and they did sit-ins yeah cops
came in they followed orders and they
arrested them how isn't this weird it's
just it's just it's just so weird that
the the the way politics is evolving in
this country
i've always been on the side of
businesses should apply public should
should grant access to public
accommodation for members of the public
but now it's crazy to see many people on
the right arguing that you know what i
mean
like before
it's just
i don't know man i saw i saw a really
crazy image of a uh a building a vaccine
warehouse being burned down and someone
on the right being like this is how you
stick it to authoritarianism or whatever
and i'm like bro that's an anti-fatigue
the difference there is their anger is
rooted in something that's really
happening and sometimes i think that and
antifa are rioting they're writing over
manipulated realities yep you know like
exactly numbers of you know deaths or
whatever um you know like i had a friend
who would tell me like thousands of
black men die you know a year right by
cops and i'm like
i don't know if that's the number it's
like 23. i would show her the number she
would say well the numbers are
systemically racist
and i was like and then i'm racist for
showing her the systemically racist oh
my goodness i had i had a friend
and uh they were posting stuff about the
migrant crisis
that was wrong so i took and i took the
the refugee document on from the un
website
sent her the link and said hey just fyi
what's going on here is x y and z the
people coming from the the so there's
three mediterranean routes there's the
western the central and the eastern i
think i don't think it's called central
but there was three routes one goes
through spain one goes through from
libya through italy and then one goes
through greece through lesvos and i was
just like the people who are coming in
through greece are the refugees from
afghanistan and iraq and the people who
are coming from the central and western
routes are economic migrants from
nigeria and other countries and then she
just said screw you and blocked me oh
and i was like i don't know what just
happened she slapped your microphone
yeah i didn't soldier i didn't call her
name i had one friend this was crazy
someone i talked to all the time we hung
out a lot in new york
who told me that they now believed in
conversion therapy
because they
so this is crazy right check this out if
you talk to someone on the left they
will cheer
when you hear someone say you know like
canada has banned conversion therapy
they'll go like yay
and i'm talking to this friend she's a
woman
and she was saying that it was
transphobic for people to not want to
date people of the same sex if they were
transgender and so i was like hold on
let me let me like i'm trying to
understand you so i was like you're a
woman and you're attracted to men and
she was like yes and i said so so you're
saying that you personally
are attracted to bile like people who
are biologically female who have female
genitalia but have transitioned and she
said no
and i said so do you think that's
transphobic and she said well i could
learn to like it and i said isn't that
conversion therapy like grooming like
changing some like trying to convert
someone's sexuality and then she got
really mad and said no you're being
transphobic and i was like i thought you
were being transphobic i was like all i
did was genuinely she blocked me yeah
she but but to be fair she deleted all
of her social media and said i can't
take this anymore and i i think what
really happened is
like when we talk with with ra these are
people who are on facebook these are
people on twitter
and they get a worldview bubble bubble
world from the group they follow this is
what people need to understand
who you follow on twitter if you're
active on twitter is shaping your
reality and it can be distorting it so
they say like
like so i follow a lot of conservative
personalities a lot of leftist and
liberal personalities i follow hassan i
follow vosh i folly
folly i follow a few other people i
don't want anyone else dragged they're
famous so i'll leave it there but a few
other like lesser well-known leftist
journalists as well as all the
mainstream publications vice
and uh that way i'm seeing what they're
saying i'm seeing what people are saying
and i get a view of
both you know
groups
but a lot of these people like this this
you know former friend of mine was
probably only on facebook in a group of
friends who were all regurgitating the
same woke garbage and then when i simply
asked questions i think what really
happened was she realized the world she
lived in on facebook was not real and
she couldn't take the pressure of it
anymore and deleted it
scary i would even go further it's not
who you follow it's who the big tech
algorithms decide you see because now it
doesn't even matter because they curate
a lot of the timelines twitter is still
one of the few places where you actually
see the people you actually follow but
most social media especially facebook
and instagram they have a carefully
curated algorithm that they have even
done psychological studies on that could
create certain emotional outcomes and
there i i think there's a correlation
between the the the mental and uh
wellness
of just people going down dramatically
with the onset of social media but it's
not just our personal well-being that's
being affected here it's not just our
mental health it's also our political
discourse which is being bastardized and
i think the echo chambers that are
created the echo chambers that many
people blindly follow because also as
you mentioned him you try to get
different perspectives but a lot of
people don't a lot of people don't want
to see different perspectives they want
to see their perspective regurgitated uh
to them from different kind of points
you also might not have time
re-establishing the same idea
reinforcing that idea i got to pull
something up that's really funny
but you know keep keep talking i think i
think this is my crazy wacky theory is
facebook years ago remember that debate
over if it's a blue dress or a gold
dress yeah that was us getting prepped
for the fracturing of reality who
believes what and they're just back
there they're judging who does what i
should do a report i can't do it with
facebook and instagram now i think i'm
shadow bit on instagram even when people
do see my post half the time it has that
warning over it like fact checkers have
deemed this false it'll be like the most
mundane thing badge of honor it's not
even like crazy i saw something on
twitter earlier it was someone talking
smack on vaccine mandates and right
below it was a promoted pfizer tweet let
me let me let me pull up this story for
you guys tim poole confirmed leftist
this is from ground.news blind spotter
and it says 53 percent of the news tim
cast interacts with on twitter leans
left top three influencers are vosh
michael malus and jack pasobic
perfectly balanced as all things should
be now to be fair the reason why it says
most of the news i interact with liens
left is because it's the new york times
it's cnn it's newsweek these are
mainstream news publications
they lean left
the media has a leftist bias or a
liberal bias michael malus is slightly
leaning left with a big you know right
wing right there vosh is overwhelmingly
left and jack is overwhelmingly right
this right here is really fascinating
first of all i'm obviously not a leftist
but i think it's fair to say that on
policy issues and certain certain issues
i am center-left you know libertarian a
little uh you know difference and
opinion from luke in some ways but when
you look at vosh his world view is
comprised almost exclusively of leftist
media michael malus's worldview is mixed
between liberal and conservative media
and jack posobik is a little bit of
liberal media but mostly conservative
media this makes total sense based on
the way the way they interact with me to
the things they believe the things they
say
why does vosh think that you know the
first time he came here he said tim paul
he told me to my face you're far right
because the only media he interacts with
is left media who make up you know
garbled nonsense about me
now he says conservative why because he
actually came here and interacted with
me and now like he comes here and we
agreed on a bunch of stuff in fact when
we had the charlie kirk and vosh debate
i was actually met a lot of the stuff he
said i was like i agree with you you're
correct that point is true and these
things are true and then a lot of people
follow them were like oh i didn't
realize you know they're like based tim
and things like that if these people
just mixed up their news sources a
little bit got a healthier balance
everyone might actually calm down the
problem is
new york times cnn newsweek my top three
sources they lean left so if vosh is
just watching msnbc cnn reading the
nation and all that stuff and it's
overwhelmingly left media
then i don't know how you break someone
out of that that broken reality can you
put anyone's twitter
you want me do you yeah yeah
luke we are change luke we are change
it's going to be like he's a crackpot
conspiracy guy look at that
44 left 44 left bro it's because the new
york times zero heads zero hedges
but it's because the new york times is a
left-wing publication
so when you when you like ground news is
a good job of this
look at that thomas massey glenn green
and cernovich are your sources and
they're great glenn greenwald is very
left when it comes to the media yeah wow
and then you've got cernovich who's very
balanced interestingly look how small
the center centrist is in cernovich
massey's got a little bit bigger one
luke you've got a 21
moderate
let's see uh let's go back to mine
because what was the percentage of
moderate for me 23
center but most of it leans left why the
mainstream press is a liberal media
machine and this proves it let's let's
let's jump over to watch look at this he
only interacts with 64 left wing the new
york times the daily beast and ajc
what percent i can't i can't even see
the percent of right
head ken clippenstein and hassan the sun
all overwhelmingly left personalities so
vasha's world view is inherently broken
because he's not consuming media from
other people he's in an echo chamber
where he hears what he wants to hear and
i knew i mean no disrespect i you know i
respect that he was he was actually
being uh fair to a certain degree when
he was talking about the r.a thing he
would like like he said if it was any
other mixed race person complaining
about racism you would be on their side
but because tim poole you don't like him
he is correct about that you know what i
think
vosh i think is a smart guy
i think if he actually started adding in
some non-left-wing news even like some
well he needs to mix in a little bit of
conservative sources he'd be like well
hold on how wait this right-wing source
says x but the new york times says why
where is that where's the break here and
i'll give you a really good example the
washington examiner reports that the
january 6 committee admits to doctoring
the the message from jim jordan to mark
meadows that is a fact
what did the independent report
jim jordan confirms he sent message to
mark meadows
the objective truth is the message was
from jim jordan and it was
altered
now if you only read the left source you
probably don't know it was it was
altered really good example when we had
hunter avalone on the show and he said
joe biden didn't do anything wrong with
the quid pro quo and he didn't know
anything about victor shoken and
zlatchevsky and and and anything that
happened with barisma and i did
because not only did i read the
conservative outlets the mainstream
outlets i literally read ukrainian news
sources on what was going on
so if you have people like vosh who only
consume echo chamber content that's what
you get shoe on head look at this even
chuanette is 76 she's worse than vosh
but she does have 13
you know uh conservative in there and
she just interacts for the most part
with people who are on the left this is
really interesting let's take a look at
a a a conservative personality jack
posobik he's overwhelmingly right-wing
and he consumes media from people who
are also overwhelmingly in the
right-wing sphere i think it's fair to
say you look at how people consume news
and you can predict their viewpoints and
how they view the world i think
everybody even jack
should be reading a lot more of
mainstream news sources
well i i say jack should read more
mainstream news sources because he's
clearly getting more right-wing sources
and you know voss should meet read more
right-wing and independent sources
because he's clearly getting nothing but
mainstream sources you should treat it
like crossing the street you don't only
look right when you're crossing the
street especially in new york city with
the crazy drivers that they have in
there you look left and you look right
before crossing the street and i think
you know that's a perspective that's
gone for a lot of people a lot of the
people don't want to face a different
reality than the one that they're
codified in that the one that they feel
safe in and a lot of people do feel safe
by having their kind of political voices
reinforced their beliefs reinforced and
i'm a big fan of just waking them up
shocking them as much as you can and
having them wake up to the true reality
of the world this is why i think ben
right here we have ben shapiro this is
why i think ben shapiro is so smart
so quick
and why he's
like his opinions are crafted by facts
and he doesn't get everything right i
don't agree with all of his opinions but
you can see here from his ground news
blind spotter 38 of his news is left
wing 18 percent is is moderate and 44
his right wing it makes sense ben's a
conservative guy he follows people who
are you know consume middle of the road
across the board look at this steve
miller red steez
healthy news diet in the middle these
are the people that i think you know you
are doing a good job
when ben has a debate with someone like
malcolm nance and he nails all of his
facts and his opinions are are crafted
by those facts
well-read right yeah from from good
sourcing and mixing it up and trying to
understand both sides i grew up with
like 10 channels and my dad's like a
centrist lean's right but he would
always tell us like you gotta watch
everything like and i would always
notice when he got into like friendly
debates at thanksgiving or something
he would know the other person's
argument if they happen to be on the
other side better than they knew his
argument so he's arguing their point and
his point and they're hearing things
from him that are completely like from
another world to them so it's even being
able to to to be willing to have those
conversations a lot of people are afraid
of having those conversations they're
prevented at having those conversations
so even though yesterday was kind of a a
crap show the conversation at least
happened people were kind of forced to
have it and i think there's a layer of
it too that we could still salvage from
the craziness and some kind of
understanding from where other people
are coming from and i think one of the
biggest signs of intelligence is being
able to have an open mind if you're able
to hear ideas that are critical of yours
without having an emotional reaction and
you could logically critically think
about them and assess the facts of the
case very few people do that they just
want to be emotionally click-baited into
something that makes them feel nice and
and reinforces their side let me tell
you why brian stelter will never never
be on par with ben shapiro
and this is a good example 90 of what he
interacts with as a media correspondent
for cnn is left-wing media oliver darcy
who is a media correspondent for cnn 85
left-wing content these are the guys who
are supposed to be covering the right
they don't even read it reliable sources
the media show on cnn is 99
left-wing media
they do not interact with anyone but
themselves these guys are sitting at the
bottom of a well talking to each other
about
actually you know what they're they're
the people sitting in the cave the
allegory of the cave looking at the
shadows thinking they know the world and
they're not interacting with it at all
so this is something that i mentioned to
olivia when i was driving her over
because i was like i don't want to argue
with someone who doesn't understand what
we're talking about i want someone who's
well-read well-informed someone who can
change my perspective because they know
facts that i don't like talking about
redlining and blockbusting that's stuff
i want to know about because that
changes my view on stuff like systemic
racism but it's very hard to find
someone on the left maybe it's just
because it's easier to only read
left-wing sources like what brian
stelter apparently is doing i cannot
believe that these are the people that
they choose to cover the media i forget
who it was who was advertising for a
right-wing media like reporter i was
like well as far as i know as far as
these people are telling me the right
wing doesn't even exist there is none
yeah i i think there's also a debate to
be had with
a lot of people on the left wanting to
give handouts wanting to help others so
they don't have to work towards
something because when you have an idea
that contradicts your viewpoint you have
to work to combat it and i think there's
an aspect of people having the ability
to be able to work and i think maybe
that's why a lot of right-wingers are
for work
for having this kind of protestant work
ethic uh compared to people who want to
be the mother in our kind of larger
society and give people help and be
their supportive role and i think a
healthy society has a mother a mother
figure and a father figure that has
both kind of influence on people's lives
so they get a fair perspective on it
because if you go too far in either
direction uh you're going to be in an
unhealthy direction you're going to be
unbalanced and you're not going to be a
person that's going to kind of fare well
uh with the kind of rules and
circumstances of our society so i want
to pull up this is called mediapoly from
ground news you can see 32 percent of
the news tim poole interacts with on
twitter is media conglomerate owned
timpool is a slightly concentrated news
diet so you can see 11 percent of the
news i consume is independent or i just
say i think it's uh interacts with
mostly mainstream media then private
equity then wealthy private owners
telecom companies and other
i wanna do this i'm gonna pull up
look at all this let me go back i'm to
pull up luke we are change
and i'm willing to bet luke has a here's
my bet luke's going to have a big
independent media bubble what do you
think luke probably do you think so no
no not so much bigger actually smaller
than mine but
you have wealthy private owners
followed by media conglomerates and
private equity but here's the reason
here's why here's why i pulled this up
what do you think is going to happen
when i pull up brian stelter yeah
let's find out brian stelter media
reporter for cnn oh he he's
overwhelmingly telecom companies now
that's probably because cnn
because he he he's within the cnn bubble
reliable sources 96
telecom
oliver darcy telecom
these th these people live not only in
in a bubble of leftism but they only
really interact probably with with the
news come out of their own network which
is full of garbage and as we can see
heavily biased so they're they're
effectively the way described it with
jack dorsey
is that his worldview was shaped by
gargling the sewage of of his own
platform he created a platform it had a
net it had a negative effect on society
producing extreme activism he then
consumed it all and came to believe the
garbage coming out of his own machine
stop it man you're getting you're giving
me uh i got it i got to see him
literally doing that
i think jack dorsey has been unleashed
i think he was constrained a bit by
twitter being the ceo now that he's out
the one thing he tweeted was transitory
in quotes he tweeted that rothbard
recently yeah i'm willing to bet now
that he's not there he's gonna give it
some time he might come out and actually
start blowing people's minds no joke
that'd be nice would be great i hit him
up actually he uh this would be great to
interview i asked him if you want to
come on the show and talk about his
views on blockchain you know and and the
future of social media and he said um at
some point that'd be great well he's
huge more than i can say for a lot of
other people he's huge into
decentralized currencies and him you
know tweeting out rathbar it just is
just a perfect example of people
realizing the true power of
decentralization and understanding that
if you try to control everything in life
and centralize power you're creating
real life harm that translates to of
course the natural stopping of human
progression thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time